هذا بحضوركم جميعاً أمتي
أعدك في حضورك
لن أتوقف في الداخل
لهذا الشعب
المعارك التي نجمعها
ملء البلاد باللاجئين غير الشرعيين
سنقاتل مع
قتال مع أولئك الذين يبيعون الجنسية مقابل أجر ضئيل
سنقوم
عقارات لبيع الشقق للأجانب
سنقاتل مع من يدعم في البلاد
مع عصابات قطعت الكهرباء عن الملايين
سنقاتل مع هذه الإيجارات
سوف نحارب التضخم
القتال مع أولئك الذين سلموا مافيانا للمافيا
سوف نتعامل مع أباطرة المخدرات
سوف نقاتل مع أولئك الذين
أولئك الذين دفنوا شرفهم في الحدائق القنصلية
سنقاتل مع
هو
نصف يوم
خاضع للسياسة
إرسال الفرنسيين على طائرات خاصة
شعبنا
قتال مع الذين يأخذون المطر من السجون
سنجعل المليارات من الناس تتعرق
سنحارب بائعي الباب الخلفي
إذن باختصار
لذلك ملخصات القتال مع أولئك الذين يبيعون الوطن
سنقوم
اشترك